welcome welcome to your mom's house
[Music]
turn
gene we're back from the vacation got a
great guest today one of our all-time
faves full charge is coming in real
quick before I shoot my special oh I
have a week of shows in the Midwest I'm
in Lincoln Nebraska Midwest City
Oklahoma lip-licking at Nebraska
yep and Springfield Missouri um spring
come up with something then I go to the
club that started it all for me the Brea
improv September 13th that's just a few
nights before I shoot I'm in Oaktown the
Oakland theatre sorry the Fox Theatre in
Oakland
September 14th and then two shows at the
Paramount Theatre in Denver mom lerato
the first show is sold out the second
show has like a hundred tickets left
so you hadn't gotten tickets yet this
would be the time to do it I pick up
when I go to Albany New York two shows
there the 27th Reading Pennsylvania
Portland Maine and then the Sony Center
for the Performing Arts in Toronto
Canada well Trans Canada Highway there
you go that is a really exciting for me
and then if the tour goes on from there
go to Tom Segura calm slash tour and you
can see all the dates there are a bunch
of cities still coming up gene gene
September 22nd and 23rd I'll be in st.
Lucie it's a helium comedy club and then
October 3rd in nards Ville Tennessee at
Zanies comedy club October 4th
Charlotte North Carolina at the comedy
zone and then October 8th with my mommy
doing your mom's house live in sperm
buying California yep crazy crazy crazy
maze it's gonna be nuts crazy crazy I'm
about brass balls Beach I also wanted to
say thank you to everybody
that went ahead and repurchased their
tickets in mum Australia it's bananas
good thank you guys so much a couple of
the shows are almost full so make sure
if you're there I know it's a long ways
out but get your tickets while you can I
don't know how many shows I'll be able
to do on that trip but I'll be there
it's all on my site your tickets now get
them now when is it and it's when in
April Oh April
yeah it's already like there's a couple
that are almost full yeah you gotta get
on that now yeah and I can't necessarily
stay in each city that's right more
extra days so well you're not yeah
because it's the routing and it's crazy
Australia yeah alright he's here full
time here
oh the full charge is already here yes
well let's press pause and we'll get
into it and just like that
it happened the full charge was born and
came into our life no it was it was
perfect timing
it really was we were about to like open
the show up yeah we've been having
guests but we do we'll do like a bunch
of time before them but you're one of
the people that just feels like the show
is you know still rolling your family
yeah thank you you're one of those early
moms yeah no I get in on the ground
floor you know the studio used to be
right by my house yeah I should be able
to walk over shop science yeah leave go
to 7-eleven you get your two hotdogs
dinner see Brendon Walsh eating 7-eleven
pizza yeah speaking of that unacceptable
7-eleven pizza no one should do it it's
unacceptable and that's the thing I mean
if you can get McDonald's for a dollar
why would you get ghettoize pizza for
two dollars right like 7-eleven food to
go is there's a real dicey I remember in
high school we would do in Florida they
have Cuban sandwiches but it's basically
a hot pressed sandwich right and when
you've been drinking that is the most
amazing sandwich ever but if you're
sober shouldn't be eating there well we
used to eat sober post skateboarding
which is a little bit of a high yeah
but we were young enough to
comic 7-eleven chili and nacho cheese
that's the other thing is youth
definitely confirm yeah your son never
gained weight you never get sick I used
to drink like a six or a beer and then
you come home and order I'll I got full
pepperoni pizza yeah you know 1:00 in
the morning yeah all right eat that go
right to sleep I haven't done that since
July just right there ready to go weird
all rule should be shouted all good
rules yeah SpiceJet all right
it doesn't sound smart but he says smart
thing here's the thing he's not even a
woman that's a woman what's a woman stop
it here's the opening clip check it out
pain hit me in my belly I jumped up was
fast as I could get up and I started
heading for the bathroom and I shit on
myself before a copter don't bring
anyone love into this
[Music]
Christina
it's funny people would think that I
queued you up though talking about
that's what I was thinking it just
happened is this kind of the energy
between the three of us yeah sin has
always been that way always will be that
way you know what I remember pacifically
at that 7-eleven yeah is there's that
miscellaneous dog it's not it's in the
hot dog section it's not a hot dog
it looks like ground beef but in the
shape of a hot dog you know it's got
bumps on them yeah yeah well what's the
bumpy is it ground beef oh no one's
really asked
I think the bumps start to come to when
it's been sitting on that heat plate for
a long time there's something special I
haven't had a 7-eleven hot dog probably
about 3035 years but they grease it up
baby and there is a certain amount of
magic to see how it's always on that
roll yeah yeah you put canola oil or
lard or whatever on there give it
actually very good yeah I'm not gonna
eat it no but it's good mr. Kaul Tate
Tate Jeff Tate lived in our couch for
like five days and ate hot dogs and
Gatorade for a week
yeah man there's burrito king right
there brew king was right there
fucking hard times pizza right there I
know sushi the fuck's he thinking
although hard times gave me diarrhea
every time yeah but still better than
7-eleven that's what's called hard time
soft time loose stools I work for that
guy loose time you did I worked at a
pizza place that that he opened after
hard times uh-huh I had a job there I
used to serve slices and salads oh good
and then one day I just didn't show up
and then I called him and I was like oh
I can come in this week like the week
after it was like you can't come
because I called someone else didn't
they tell you I tried to like come up
with the line the nerve I was like now I
was saying he was weird though you're
one of those people that can quit the
job or not quit and then come back I
always and like that's a lot of nerve
because in my world I was always too
ashamed to show my face again
oh yeah I worked at a video duplication
place for nine years and I quit and got
fired several times and I still got to
go back every time Wow yeah I mean I
think I quit twice and I got to go back
three times or go back twice that's
impressive
yeah kind of yeah I mean it's it's
impressive that I got the job back but
it's not impressive that I moved there
for nine years that's true
but I mean it's still important for nine
years that that the level either that
you were so good at it or that they
didn't have people willing to replace
it's so funny combination of things
basically what I did was look up
videotapes all day that was in the
library yeah and so all I had to do was
basically a Google search but back then
no one knew how to do a Google search
right crazy yeah and then we see some
wild shit on tape and all those I don't
watch anything nothing which is
hilarious because people call me up and
they go yes the one with the dog eating
rice krispies and I'm like I don't watch
these tapes man you got to give me a
title you know what I mean they were I
just like looked up tired what about
like was there ever any any you know
moment of somebody saying like you guys
see this and that somebody pulls you and
look at if something ever mmm the first
time the first day of work they handed
me the South Park pilot and they're like
take this home and watch it what's
completely illegal right but I did it I
wanted to see it I loved that
that was great yeah the Brian Boitano
ice skating yeah aspect before shit was
dirty and this was a dirty it wasn't
Clooney in that one to like that I don't
think so or he financed that or
something maybe he became a fan of that
yeah he was in later episodes I think I
think he was an early on financier or at
least he was publicity and that he saw
it and was like telling people like you
guys see this absolutely yeah and the
guy that worked at my work was
advertising hard - oh yes
I don't want to mention his name because
it's illegal as hell but I do remember
his name
I got a copy of The Blair Witch Project
on VHS like a bootleg copy and it was
before people made movies like that
where it was like is this real or not
and I thought it was they really nailed
the hype like they really nailed getting
you to like there were so many people
that believed that that was real I did
that's before you saw anything like that
I thought oh my god whatever people say
it's this thing that people are saying
is real right right come on
I was sitting in traffic on Santa Monica
Boulevard and I had Maryland plates
still mm-hmm and that plate it's these
kids pulled up to me and they're like
hey bro
Blair Witch is that she real because I
have Maryland plays hilarious always
just randomly asking me Maryland bro my
favorite is no I'm smart to just ask you
do you wanna hear this lady's story okay
a couple things with this go ahead thank
god she's terrifying oh I couldn't
believe that was a woman oh you got to
play the moose suit lady for full charge
- oh yeah yeah first I went to the store
with Jake mom we play pro if we come
home and my belly button feeling too
good and Jake and his mom had left it
went back to the store she forgot some
ice but stories really I'm gonna send it
I wonder who she voted for for president
yeah all right exactly for the bathroom
yep and I shit on myself before a doctor
okay
yeah I come out of the bathroom and I
headed up I come close to put about
about that time Jake this mom come in
what happened
Jake looked at walk trough it smells
shit here okay that's probably cuz you
see yourself like you said five minutes
earlier you would have seen my big dick
and Asshur going to bust our way you say
big dick and ass no but she but it
sounded like it she said she actually
said you'd have seen my big naked ass oh
but her accent is so perfect it sounds
like you said you had to see my big yeah
yeah this is an entirely different
dialect of English yeah this is the
equivalent of Scottish versus the
English yeah they would have trouble
with her I think yeah yeah no big
dicking s well I know but yeah that's a
funny answer well that worked on me
that's when I got home and they left
again
so don't buy no fucking pizza again
SpiceJet
alright meanwhile Brendon Walsh walks
away unscathed every time for years yeah
a couple things I love about this video
one is your promise yes yeah she got a
little snore noises on her pajamas
zzzzz and there's sheeps on them right
you count the sheets yeah yeah yeah and
the other one is that like for some
reason I can hear I know this is on
video but I can hear a film camera
shooting at 24 frames a second that is
about that could just be like an oxygen
tank that you think confess to shitting
their pants yeah we know everything's
going straight to the internet now yeah
straight to know I feel like you just
know life's been rough though with her
right like right away you know it hasn't
been peaches no but I'm always astounded
as it been plum juice I'm always
astounded when Americans only speak one
language when they can't get it right
right this is the only language you're
speaking you're struggling really
struggling yeah yeah
and Danna and also you've been doing it
for years this is like 60 years of
trying the one language
there's no come out the bathroom me seem
a big dick and ass big dick and banging
her
I mean you think she talked like that
was just 20 she spoke like that maybe no
I think people like think it's fun and
cute to talk like that and this part of
their charm and it gets more disgusting
as time goes on right like it's her
charm that she can't conjugate properly
or yeah it's folksy it's kind of
charming her PJs only full charge have
seen moose speaking out ladies with
accents have you seen the moose soup
lady no oh man well this this is really
really taken our show by storm people
are really into this okay well the irony
is you may not you're not gonna see you
don't see her but but you still when I
say I know you can picture her yeah I
know you can picture what I could
describe her just by listening there we
put it you get a good couple of minutes
with her have you guys ever seen her
afterwards yes yeah okay not I mean we
were we were what I'm gonna show you is
exactly how we experienced Karis time
I'm kk' I'm ready I think this is
Charlie freaking
oh my god check your passenger son of a
bitch
damn it dirty bitch is that journey Oh
dirty son of a come down mayor promote
soup mousse mousse soup yeah all right
you guys are doing good son of a bitch
hey I got you on video dirty son of a
oMG how do you can vote everywhere I
mean so a couple things sure can picture
her right I don't know I I know she
voted for Hillary I know that much yeah
I think I think I can yeah I'm wondering
what's why was she so upset she said you
guys were doing so good
they're racing they're in a race oh okay
I was just telling them you guys are I
thought you said you're no good just
like riding in a boat yeah a couple
minutes ahead of Charlie oh yeah so
she's telling them good job get your
passenger and get going and then come
over for moose soup this is your asses
later does the story continue is there
any moose suit well we know there's
moose soup but we don't actually ever
get to see it but we were so we were so
just excited by the prospect of moose
yes that we you know people were
basically hunting for his woman and and
they found her I mean it wasn't yeah
she's on Facebook and stuff so I think
she looks just like the last lady yeah
you know what interesting Lena I think
you I think you're right I think there's
some parallels
the most soup ladies younger than the
pizza shit yes I mean the stories go
together
it's don't eat at a gas station right
musu right is the same it's just
different parts of the same lesson
you're a hunter Tom fill er up sealer
shut is it the mousse soup lady or is it
pizza shit Oh mousse soup a hundred
percent I'm going to those soup lady's
gonna take care of you picking mousse
soup probably cuz I haven't seen her yet
it's what you think it is it is but I
think it's better than Pizza shit I do
kind of want to get a look at that big
dick and ass so we were in breast Paul's
Beach Florida yeah at the improv we have
to say I think it said a new bar for
most fun ever alive it was more more
funner than a lot of yeah it was bananas
I think Florida in general they come out
and they come out to have fun but doing
the podcast there was I mean they were a
raucous crowd and just the people know
because we've had issues before hired a
sound engineer
yes premium audio and I've checked it
it's amazing have HD video so in I think
next week we'll put up even with some
behind the scenes footage - really
really fun but it was it was an awesome
podcast yeah it was really special
it really was top top view definitely
yeah top yeah I mean it was so so into
it it was really fun to do that one were
you guys anywhere near top dog and clan
we saw we saw top dog did see Christina
do is stand-ups and now we're talking
Chara there she learning
31 right yeah and still better than the
name bouncing i'd go retarded dog was
their top doctor in 70 wow that was the
whole reaction the whole reason we went
and we scheduled everything was because
he was turning 70 and what oh I forgot
that I actually saw top dogs legs oh
yeah it was the third time one time in
his boxers in the kitchen and the
paper-thin boxers second time when I saw
his balls on the cruise yep and then
this time he actually wore shorts
bathing suit bottoms unassuming and
we're at the beach at the hotel at the
beach and we're about to go down it's
like hey do you want to come and hang
out with the you know your grandson he
was like yeah because I didn't bring a
shirt all you had was buttoned down that
dress-up shirt ah so I had to give a
t-shirt to wear because he had none I'm
like you're here for days you're not
bringing a I forgot yeah and then we did
see his pale white leg oh my god they've
never seen daylight no they haven't hair
on them or they just the hair falls out
with the years I didn't know that I
didn't know that yeah socks and pants
and shit we're down they wear it down
yeah yeah I got a situation
socks on socks oh yeah the lower leg
hair goes first from all the socks yeah
long long road to eating pizza Attica
you peek way too early
yeah yeah it's like 25 yeah and then you
just head down for another 60 70 years
yeah yeah take me now jeez yeah and it's
just a maintenance program then there's
a point where the maintenance doesn't
count like we saw so many people on
death's door that's a - that's what you
do people go there to get ready to die
if the age don't kill you bath salts
will Oh goddamn but then on the other
side we saw like super Fitness dads and
super Fitness moms like over these are
people who when you have children
there's no really not that kind of time
to be super fit like it's
anomaly if you're in like amazing ripped
shape there's like there's always one
like one or two Fitness dads and then
like this I think somebody might be a
professional like I think we just didn't
recognize a professional athlete Sears
yeah he was super Fitness dad I mean he
was 6-3 yoked with his blonde hair
thrown back either looked like a
supermodel or an international whatever
soccer volleyball player or something
that do did not look like anybody else
normal it was genetically superior don't
know but then there's the fitness moms
who totally washboard abs impossible
well you gotta have a babysitter and a
regimen yeah yeah yes yeah that's
actually the biggest ingredient you got
to value it and have the discipline
sleep - you gotta sleep a lot yeah I
don't know I don't know man I like to be
thin but I want to put down much work I
want to try to be perfect that's it and
that's the difference full-charge you
nailed it it's like being acceptable in
shape versus perfect because perfect is
just that's your whole focus is your
you're going towards that all the time
how about people are hot as shit but
then like oh but I got this little thing
of fat right here taking off even though
they're smoking hot I want to go from a
nine and a half to a ten fuck you I know
there are some people's gauge like some
people's limit for fat is so funny you
know like one time I remember once I'm
traveling with Brogan and we were in a
car on the way to a hotel and we're in
the back of the car and he goes I'm
getting fat he pinched like between his
index finger and his thumb you know it'd
be like if you're trying to peel a
band-aid off that and he was like I'm
getting fat and this was like I mean
this is right like 10 yen I was like we
talked about but that was fat for him
right he was like yeah I gotta go we
gotta crack this I got to write this
ship right now and I've been eating too
many Brussels sprouts man yeah cut down
on that shit my carbs yeah
alright okay dude like that Tolia that
made such an impact that I still
remember it yeah I was like what the
fuck are you talk that's I feel like my
bar is low ish I'm like as long as I'm
not overweight like i've had cellulite
since I was 12 and I just don't care I'm
like man like my time my stepsister was
like you know you can run and not house
I don't care it's fine it's fine who
sees it like Tom yeah I don't wear
shorts you know I remember where these
khaki for me it was like what started
the whole weight loss thing was just
looking at Burt it's true and just
thinking like I don't want to end up
like that that's cautionary tale yeah so
that was that's what did it for me just
don't be Burt don't be him yeah that's a
good bar to have yeah that makes sense
yeah did you see he did like a green
screen promo laughs yeah I did and
people sent in like they they fucked
with his green screen so you know he did
this know we did some he went in front
of a green screen and like was like do
whatever you want to this video okay and
then people have make me cry this is
hilarious
what's nothing green good luck I want to
see I will say Birds a great house
here's a good home nobody really found
an edible I made sure to hold these till
after the day so they're over those
little dots do how do they have a name I
don't know what he's doing
[Music]
[Laughter]
play one that's weird a shit huh yeah so
weird that he's still like yeah he's a
machine you're the retarded Carly
everybody's got their hook we got my
parents to both vote to be retarded what
do we get we gave them would you rather
uh-huh and we got both of them decided I
forget what the other option was for
your dad it was to eat Asia
oh yeah he's like we'd rather eat Asian
food for the rest of your life or be
retarded retarded really yeah is that
how much he hates the Vietnamese from
the war he was like his first and only
dog they'd rather eat Asian pursued it's
the Asian cuisine and all of it he's
like no dog here's the thing is that we
actually snuck an Asian appetizer in
yeah at that place we know that whatever
nice Wagyu beef yeah that was marinated
in like some Szechuan sauce he didn't
even sing it he loved it yeah that's
true and there was Korean short ribs
that's what it was yeah
no there's to your
new things yet so for his mother a dog
in it we had a restaurant when he said
that no okay but I'm saying
we ended up feeding him yeah yeah yeah
Asian and he was delicious
yeah like that's part of it walk up to a
cashier at McDonald's who is Asian and
say speak Chinese or he told your sister
make her speak Chinese hey take my order
in Chinese said top dog he's so in
trying to put weight on his legs he does
that I mean I had like a joke about it
in my act for a while but it's totally
true where if you said you know I don't
know if you said you're German he would
find a way to bring up World War two
ah you know I mean just because like he
just he goes for this Jam the
information that he knows okay same
thing with race like if you're like you
know I'm if you said I'm Japanese yes at
some point he'd be like yeah Reza's
Pearl Harbor so he's about race and he
likes and he likes it to work out where
I mean in his perfect world you're gonna
talk about the thing like in today's
world I think people be like why are you
just because I'm this doesn't mean that
was like but in his world and his mind
that is right that is connecting with
you you're just associated with that off
Hitler teacher from Germany totally yeah
or if you're black he would definitely
be like I mean he wouldn't bring it up
but eventually like if you know sports
would come up he he would hope that he'd
be like play football he just he's on in
yeah he would hope that you'd be like
yeah I play me like yeah yeah that's
true like rap he does bring up like the
five things he knows about you like Cena
you studied philosophy I'm like yeah 20
years ago
we have this ongoing thing now elbowing
you under the table
today's phone call boys she's he still
he's still on that he is on this thing
of course Christina smart right brings
it up he says not that smart
he says in a way where the implication
is how are you able to keep up like is
the way he talks to me talking about
that's the lesser of two evils though I
guess yeah your wife you know dad could
say to his son and wife his shit yeah no
I mean he's like God God is she he says
it like that every time he's like god
she's constantly I'm like yeah do you
know why well my trick is sincerely it's
that when I sit down with him I just
bring up stuff that he enjoys talking
about right about Vietnam and then he'll
be like how did you take shits man John
smart and then he thinks I'm super smart
but I'm just asking him about stuff that
he enjoys talking about which makes what
feeds the ego yeah walks way going man
I'm so sorry I am interesting but I
haven't which means by the way that you
are smart for figuring that out right
yeah I just grew up having to
accommodate adult softball pitches for
that okay I wasn't expecting this this
is interesting this is not an entry
level episode folks know what Nana not
her idea so for those of you not
watching this woman just took a bunch of
bananas put it on her ass and then
farted and this is the kind of stuff I'm
talking about when I talk about fart
mistress calm which is what we're trying
to get my mother to do what yeah so we
brought fart history and this is why
your dad's like your wife's really smart
for coming up with this dumb shit
so exactly now mistress calm and if you
if you go to the site you can send a
message to my mother encouraging her to
be the fart mistress
how does she receive this message she
goes from email it goes to us now I can
send them to her and a bunch of come in
and we we really were trying to get her
to do basically what the fart princess
is doing right here uh-huh
which is you know just do authentic I
love this videos just know she squirting
on a spread oh and then she smells see
this is the kind of stuff I'm talking
about why not make the genre interesting
exciting to the view and look she's got
a nice place to live this is nothing no
that's that's the house that flatulence
bill yeah cigarettes so she's got her
cigarette she's gonna she's farting on
her Marlboros
what's blue maybe Green is actually nice
now if she were smart she'd have a film
container and then she could smell it
later if she sealed it
I like how she's surprised yeah I like
that she's being creative with the
titles with the names of these things
yeah pretty cool
I received some emails about this my
film container I don't know if you know
this full charge but if you fart into an
old film container it'll seal in the
smell and you can mail it across the
country across the globe and your friend
can open it and smell your fart I like
that yeah
fart a gram that's right would say yeah
right well did you ever do that by the
way no no never done it have you
no I didn't but I mean I was around you
know I had my old roommate Kevin did and
he sent me a fart in England why didn't
it work but that's a good far they got
shitty food over there yeah but anyway
some other people suggested just
Tupperware to like where's a good
suggestion as well and we've also had
people offer to send us film containers
this one photographer sent over a bunch
of em I was gonna say if you're gonna
send your farts you don't need to do
that no no it sounds a fartist the
containers appearance
what a day this woman's having she's
farting on the Apple and then she has to
smelly animal she's gonna eat it though
farple you got it keep working on hard
apples this is like a Tarantino movie
like this is a young version of the
woman that shit her pants that's right
she used to be so good right farting
yeah that she never drew mud and now
she's so pissed yeah you're right about
her big dick and dick and balls
jammies wouldn't that be something if
she looked like that back in the day she
probably looked a lot better than she
looks now I think so yes how does that
happen though no I think she was a hard
20 you think so yeah yeah I think she
was a good look at 16 16 that was the
last year a hard 20 because you know
what I mean like there's no way you can
look good at 40 I don't know I just feel
like how old do you think that woman is
the one that shit her pants it's tough
to say that it's tough to say see that's
the thing I've noticed younger than you
think
I bet attention to this so much more
lately how different like once you hit
50 there are people there are guys and
women that are 53 that look like they're
gonna die tomorrow and then there's
people in their 70s even 80 the that
look I'm eight which obviously a lot of
that's genetics and surgery surgery but
also upkeep care up keeps a big part
yeah let's face it care of yeah but
genes you know you have to have I
thought you meant genes like denim for
him you have to wear jeans high and
tight now good genetics and no he can
really fall apart now I went to high
school with a girl who looked like 30
when she was 15
like she just had leathered skin it's
just genetic I look like that history
you've always looked ten years old
always nothing like you and Burt were
talking one time Burt was like yeah that
guy's our age and he like my man he's
seven years old yeah I miss that
we're not light years apart but we're
definitely the same age no but you're
definitely you've definitely grown into
your age like your dad age yeah when we
were on this vacation top dog did this
thing where he'd never rubbed in the
sunblock like you know what dads do and
they need white weights right yeah but
you have been doing that like you had
full your ears were all white and creamy
all week all week and I'd always try to
like rub it out and it just kept going
dad doesn't need to you're so ahead of
the game if you even put the shit on
what am I trying to look cool Hey ladies
I got my sunblock on you can't look cool
anymore it's like you stop trying it's
the best you know what are you gonna do
even if you pull it off somebody will
call you out Oh knows your age will call
you out yeah you're right hard 360 dunk
in your face we're set and we're at the
age now where I'm starting to get shit
we're like kids really seem like they're
their generations away from me now yeah
you know every all the things that I
would mock before everything from just
slang music when you make a reference
you just this is like a slam dunk yeah
yeah and everyone just ignores it
they're like what's WKRP instance in
there yeah yeah you know Johnny or just
the way children look at you now and you
tell them your age like 41 that just
sounds like a hundred and one two yeah
ten-year-old my niece's call me pat pat
and they laugh when they say it they
know it's an insult they do yeah it's
funny how they know that yeah my cousin
with my cousin my nephew was being super
cute and then we're on that playground
he goes hey I bet you can't do this oh
yeah and he climbed up
yeah thing and he was like swinging off
of it and jumping like this I bet you
can't do this at all
I go and I instead of like going around
with it I go anyone can do that
I'm not gonna waste my time yeah doing
that easy shit yeah yeah I know but I
also wanted to like set him straight on
talking shit like talk some shit you can
talk shit to a lot of people it's gonna
be differently right and you did it
twice you did it twice remember yeah
yeah he was like do it again
you know all right shit ain't nothing
but a thing you were swinging off a rope
and shit man jumping over this crazy
elaborate playground for kids but it was
you know it had metal bars that curved
up huh and twist it around so the kids
play with it a certain way as adults
you could grab onto the metal bars and
actually swing yourself up okay jump
over thing which is not built for that
but right you know people if you got
served so full charge we were in the
airport yesterday and this woman
standing in line in front of us thinking
on the airplane had her little Tootsie's
out she was wearing open-toed shoes okay
and we're trying we're having a debate
here whether or not cuz she had black
nail polish on the toes but the growth
of the toenail like it had been done
like five months earlier the pedicure as
what look like that it grown out at
which point it looked like really long
really long hung off the front of that
so she had black claws that were painted
black right but it looked like a French
pedicure you never seen him in black
because they uh huh I don't know I'm
debating whether or not it was a French
pedicure intentionally they were all
painted black at one point and some of
that's worn off and they've grown they
shouldn't have been out criticized if
you're showing any skin you're gonna be
criticized all I'm saying is just wrap
that shit up man wrap it up tight on a
plane yeah you'd think too cuz the nails
were so long that they would they would
hurt in their sneakers
what about clippers that no one has
Clippers anymore
you can't clip those it's just like 99
cents yeah real cheap
how does she not see that she does she
doesn't care doesn't care doesn't bother
doesn't not care maybe she's like this
is pretty hot ever we watched that TLC
show yeah that lady had crate she's like
I've never cut my toenails yes in like
40 years are all crazy long she's like I
can't get a job and like you can't get a
job you said you don't want to cut your
Tony for you to cut don't come around
here no more she could even put sneakers
on yeah they had to like cut that they
put sneakers on her feet but then they
cut off the toe part remember beautiful
tops weird fucking guy who was like yeah
I'll do anything for her he's like I
just here to help her you know like he
thought she was wonderful with her yeah
I mean they were long and curly what
happened before toe clippers Lyle's
maybe I think you walked if you came in
walking around on rocks and that kind of
filed them down or something yeah yeah
because when you let your fingernails go
I've seen in the Guinness Book of World
Records they're all twisty and turny and
yeah and they I don't know it's strange
why would God make that and if he wasn't
gonna make the toe clipper until like I
don't know 1000 AD the nail clipper is
not exactly known but the United States
patent for an improvement in a nail
clipper seemed to be in 1875 Hungarian
mentor David guest dinner man that's my
man that's a Hungarian Hungarian
invented it hung getting it works on the
principle of a lever yeah it's a simple
machine that's a fulcrum I don't know
but isn't what your spouse is for gene
to bite your toenails oh yeah yeah do
you bite his toenails oh he's asking me
all the time I didn't say to bite him I
just said you know why can't you just
clip them for me right like I'm laying
here watching TV yeah she should do
something do you know that they're
probably in for old people I understand
that old people need to have their
toenails professionally
talk to a doctor what supply and they go
and they were like a bandsaw why I think
they just grow like riddle and and super
thick so they have to like us all
I'm not ready for any of this sock me
neither and this shit is around the
corner if history has shown me anything
the time is gonna fly by surprising it's
not all clear let's see what happened
trying to figure out what happened
before them how were they cut before
tremors and if you've used a paring
knife that's how things were cut that's
so hard yeah
I'm we're getting dangerously close to
another set of fetish videos which are
unclipped toenail sex no really no I
guarantee it oh yeah you're right that's
good I guarantee it
we just opened up was everything right
yeah it's just people farting on bananas
shitty toad a bunch of videos yeah
immediately I don't even check your
Twitter the birds
super long nails dirty that's the thing
I hate that those really bother me man
et super long nails dirty nails yeah I
like them I - I keep mine nice and short
yeah people got like American flags and
shit on there now pac-man eating ghosts
or whatever just like really specific
you know the old time investment race
has been really a huge topic in this
country for the last few weeks in
America yeah I think just briefly
you mean the issue that the most
divisive issue in America is not cat
people vs. dog people not but there is a
new accusation out about how white
people are exploiting black people okay
do you want to know what it is sure it's
digital blackface oh no this listen like
a good reaction gift right you probably
noticed the most popular ones of black
people being dramatic
is digital blackface you understand
what's happening so they always cut to
black people overreacting
so gifts you know that people put in on
yeah online I know that much so they're
of every race of people yes they're
saying that the ones of black people
uh-huh you're basically almost
equivalent to blackface because because
why we're we're mocking black people
it's at the idea that they're being
they're being overreacting and Lampoon
II and yeah I feel like she needs a
translator but it took me of those
people listening who are definitely wait
what was she saying yeah her accent is
pretty strong is that you know if you
don't know blackface minstrel shows way
back in the early 1900s would portray
black people in obviously a negative
light being buffoons and that was the
thing right the guys would put shoe
polish on their face and get kicked by a
donkey
yeah act like clowns so my understanding
the Stooges right do just type and then
I told understand that being but now
it's using gifts to perform some kind of
exaggerated blackness well I'm lucky I
don't use gifts so I don't have any
white guilt over this yeah but I also
don't get it I feel like I feel like
there's this is beyond a reach
I mean people usually usually I think
when you search for gifts you search for
the emotion yeah it doesn't matter the
words you're like you type in and one of
the search engines like happy you know
excited and no matter what Kevin Hart is
gonna come our hearts going to come up
somewhere on it and it's like they're
saying if this person is saying that
that is is is unfair and racially
[Music]
expulse a I'm thankful for the old
gender bathroom I used yesterday at LAX
Airport they got him at Del Taco to
catching on
which was your pronoun when you use good
people yes I identified as man still
okay taco gendered I would I would
prefer to use an all gender bathroom yes
they always smell like homeless people
no matter what mm-hmm
at Del Taco wait a minute taco they do
what's your pronoun this is silly
talking about white people using
dark-skinned emojis she's talk about
white people using Cox can Google love
hmm this is a form of cultural
appropriation paying little respect to
someone else's culture like finally
calling out white people with dreadlocks
like it's a real thing like it's a real
disrespectful thing doesn't mean
everyone hates white people would rather
disrespectful is it racist is it
cultural appropriation yes but in a nice
way I think I think the person with
dreadlocks actually likes Bob Marley
Thanks true it's kind of maybe more than
likes gay loves these gifts and using
these emojis what if they are
entertainer I got a red camera heart and
tell him he's not here for my entertain
we're not symbols of excessive emotion
what about soup right there where he's
dancing if I have to give up Billy Dee
Williams if I have to give up like in
him dry stuff enjoying him can I do I
have to stop being entertained by okay
we did was that it yeah no definitely in
trouble oh I'm in trouble
definitely I would say doesn't it count
the spirit and watch you yes we love
this stuff and it regardless of gender
or color right I mean what I'm always
drawn to this
retard yeah that's retarded retarded
it's a very layered nuanced omission I
would say the most popular recent drop
drops are you guys are doing good rah
rah right it's an Asian guy no no no I
think we think we pass it around now we
do spread it around
everybody's Asian you making fun of
Asian people and yeah yeah all of them
now I like the thumbs up that's not as
white as I am it's like the the yellowy
one the yellow ones but what race is
that I mean that really is just clear
it's yeah that's why I like that I had
someone send me a black thumbs up one
time and I thought they were just kind
of being cool with like trying to spread
it around like it's not always about
white thumbs up Matt full run that's
cultural appropriation that's what she's
talking about
I think the black fist is you're trying
to say that's cultural power for sure
right it's clear yeah yeah I do I do the
white fist the white fist yeah do the
blackness then there's the there's the
black face with the turban I send that
one when I'm like let's go to a
different restaurant there's too many it
like let's change flights I just don't
all right why is there no gypsy emoji
[Laughter]
they're so hated they don't even get
their own emoji no way gypsy controversy
real now see I wouldn't do the black
fist because I would go like oh that's
too racist yeah I would I would pump the
brakes on that one I don't even send
emojis or gifts I'm in the clear you're
told
I don't send too many gifts either yeah
I only know the ones that are on my
iPhone really yeah I don't fucking
search for him and shit no they got
gifts on the porn sites they do so you
can send like a blowjob out to somebody
really you go to the site and they have
a
but don't send a black blowjob no that's
disrespect it's respect especially don't
send like a black woman blowing awaken
no no no no you can't do that
super disrespect aunt do that hmm what
about the other way around
mm-hmm wait wait Guayana I mean a white
girl in a black yeah that's that's
better that's better that's more raised
friend that's more respectable okay yeah
yeah you gotta be real careful with
those the world is such a landmine for
offending if you send in a black fist it
better be up a white girl's ass oh man
yeah no we're here we're officially here
with the rules so many and that's the
thing and I don't mind that people are
that habit I just feel like I love
people I don't really I don't mean any
disrespect on segura said the word gypsy
on television I didn't know gypsies had
time to watch TV and between
pickpocketing and scamming society the
fans always take it too far
fuck off gypsy yeah they do
yeah they're in a safe place yeah that's
a good one all right fuck off gypsy
gypsy bad word no but it's something
that you could have you could it's like
Mexican it's a real term but you better
not say wrong you can say it wrong right
yeah yeah definitely yeah because if you
just like that person's Mexican
sometimes people go oh and I know I'm
saying there's literally it's not a
racial slur well guys French fuck you
man we met you you made a derogatory we
met a Hungarian lady and she was saying
she she was saying that she teaches me
Hungarian uh-huh and she goes oh let's
hear what you know so I was running
through the words I know and she goes
christina goes he only knows bad words
and she goes like what and so I go like
see going which is gypsy uh-huh she goes
that's a bad word ROTC guys because I
said
[Laughter]
yeah and we ran through a few other ones
but redundant but it's yeah she taught
you low fuss or shy get back yeah it's a
horse dick in your ass yeah it's a real
common that's like a thing low fuss or
should I get back no fuss no fuss or shy
get back
shagging back I like that you know
that's because we have like go fuck
yourself
yeah which is kind of an abstract idea
yes but gift fucked by a horse cock
that's that's a real insult all the
hyung go ones are really nuts yeah very
specific look we played this on the live
show that is not out yet but I really
wanted to show full charge yeah please
were you a big Jerry Lewis fan no I mean
I have respect for my elders yeah yeah
but I did I never got I remember my mom
rented cinderfella for me and I was this
it just moved too slow for my my young
brain yeah and that's pretty much this
is like a 50 year old movie I'm guessing
yeah it's in black and white and you
know black and white what is it King of
Comedy
I liked him in that that's about all I
know he was great in that yeah yeah yeah
yeah he was great um well he did this
really cool interview yeah where he The
Hollywood Reporter interviewed him just
a short while ago actually before he
died he's 91 about being somebody in in
their 90's uh-huh working yeah he
granted them the interview it's in his
house it was voluntary if you like I'm
saying do you want to come here today
and you're saying sure and then you show
up and then you're like this why it was
there never a moment that you thought it
might be time to retire you would come
from joyfull you come from a generation
a little older and I think a Bob Hope
George Burns Sinatra people you knew
many of whom didn't want to were never
retired either do you see similarities
with them none none what do you think
drives people like you and them to want
to keep working because we do it well
you think it's a fun interview no I
think I think he just burned through
about like what he thought was gonna be
a half an hour minute like incredible
empathy for that yeah yeah yeah you can
hear him getting nervous
no well and you think that he doesn't
want to talk about that topic he gave
you a no so then if I were the
interviewer and I wouldn't be like he
doesn't want to go there thanks tarick
starts by saying we're doing this thing
about guys people who work into their
ninth like the entire oh is that lame
that's what the profile is about right
it's working
it'd be like Christina we want to talk
to you about your new special right no
all this is about where did you film the
new special I don't know yeah what do
you talk about in the special stuff how
many people showed up to the special I
don't know do you now get how fun that
would be that'd be hilarious what we hit
you the same sweater insurance and you
know why that would be extra special is
because he didn't like female comedians
yes he was actually known for shitting
on female comics you don't know lady
yeah he said that women are not funny so
actually that would be for some people
really loved him too really yeah it
wasn't my cup of tea I did like that he
did all those telethons like in the 80s
retards yeah for tards
yeah I think even said that word back
then you could say that bad yeah he sent
a retarded gift
all I should return his black gifts back
raising money for the tards about
performing now for you then say 20 years
ago how is it different for you
not at all come on man just not giving
it just stone so in like 1951 it was
it's not the same it's the same exact as
2017 totally the same yeah do you have
to make any concessions to be you know
older and you're you're performing or
does it how do you keep the material
fresh for yourself by working at it wow
this interview killed him
do we have I wonder is there footage did
he was he a stand-up or just a comedic
actor him and Dean Martin well a live
show vaudeville yeah in later years like
in the last 15 years that he would do
things like an evening with Jerry Lewis
and then you know an older crowd would
go to a nice fiat performing arts
theater you know like these places like
I don't know probably thousand-seat
venues and stuff pay top dollar and he
would come out and tell stories yeah
storyteller yeah but you didn't just
come out and go no no he didn't do that
but all guys messing songs too you know
that have you ever oh yeah I think if
you like the crowds not feeling it
you're like hey Jeff yeah you start
singing have you ever seen video footage
or photos of what Vegas was like yes
well what did it what was it like like
50 years ago in your eyes it was classy
smoking cigarettes drinking whiskey
dressed up yep all right um nobody's
wearing shorts nobody's white pasties
are showing it was kind of like but it
was also illegal activity and it was
actually kind of borderline illegal and
not for children is six years ago the
layout was obviously different too ya
know that right I mean it was the other
strip it was the other side of town
yeah and it was less far less developed
a totally different landscape how was
Vegas different for you than when you
first came here what was the first time
you you performed in Vegas 1947 can you
tell me what what Vegas was like when
you first showed up it's not it's the
same exactly the same
okay so he has disdain for this guy yeah
yeah see I'd like to see the footage
leading up to the interview did the
interviewer flub it with this with Jerry
early like was he a douche bag but he
doesn't sound like it it sounds like
he's really trying did he in advert this
right here is an impromptu question it
wasn't gonna ask him what was Vegas yeah
yeah he's trying he's like maybe I'll
talk about Vegas and there's other
footage of Jerry Lewis acting like a
dick at the telethon like shitting on
the band for playing the wrong song
Installer yeah yeah like when you show
up in 1947 what was it it wasn't a
little bit of a dusty cow town it was
what was it what was it like dusted cow
huh oh he's really now the interview
knows sort of dusty countdown know is
performing in Vegas now for you
different than it was then like yeah
he's got dressed him in his Ronald
McDonald clothes yes
went out there to chop heads down I
noticed the primary colors yeah
interesting why be a dick why I do the
interview after he's bothered maybe he's
just bothered that they're doing a piece
on old pieces of shit right he's gonna
take him down waste their time yeah if I
was the interview I'd be talking about
his hair how do you have such great hair
Jerry's notice that do you think it's
his know maybe you know the other thing
that could really bother you so he was
so famous yeah what if like the guys
like you were in a mood like what if
it's something like that yeah you
fucking shit me and that's something
that's small sets you off you know or or
or something like did you ever do movies
you know like he's like hello one little
thing like oh like did you did you
perform live shows two or something so
he'll get mad about that yeah yeah Paul
McCartney yeah Larry King both times
wait I know this I
the Seinfeld one for people that don't
know was he was doing an interview on
when Larry King Live was still on CNN
and he said like now your show was it it
was canceled or he's like what the
number we were talking about yeah and
Larry's like whoa sorry
he's like canceled the number one rated
show man with top show and he doesn't
let him off the hook at all no any and
that you could tell bothered him but he
didn't turn into this no no what did
Paul McCartney do um Larry King's like
we'll be right back with George and
Ringo and he's just like or he's like
we'll be right back with Paul and George
and Paul's like it's Ringo it's Ringo
dude you don't know who the Beatles are
right yeah yeah yeah yeah he's mad at
Seinfeld bump yes I was upset about that
yeah but it's like honestly you don't
know who the fucking Beatles are I think
it's crazy that especially you know
we're not talking about it'd be
different if right now you asked
Seinfeld it's like you're an interviewer
and you're like so what your show can't
like let's say you didn't know right but
the time you're having the biggest TV
star from the biggest show on and the
show was pretty recently over with aha
and like not let's say so you don't know
and no producer let's like how do you
not know that right and they're still
airing it yeah man like constantly you
think that show was canceled like Sally
no way
this is just pure asshole yeah I mean
this guy just really is a dick if you uh
if you want to just see his answers to
all the questions we can do well not at
all by working at it anyone that's 90
does no no 19:47 it's not it's the same
exactly the same dusted cow huh
no no he's teeth look exceptionally
great though yeah yeah I think he's got
great teeth for an old dude they can't
be his right no no these are like
veneers or something they look good
you're right and you know he did he was
smart they're not too white no they look
great
that's when you look okay he looks good
though physically 490 oh yeah he looks
great
amazing
I mean his face is sliding off of his
skull but you know what you look like
the oldest thing on his face is those
pearl visions yeah those were horrible
yes there was no good glasses in the 80s
it was a motherfucker no no poor cherry
poor Jerri
what if she got to be grumpy about
though you're like worked out bro your
beloved by everyone you have tons of
cash yeah who knows who knows that
personal life is like you know what
sucks probably for someone like that
though everyone that really he can share
a story with and laugh is dead that's
true yes sure everyone and all those
conversations are like this one was like
what was it like grandpa yeah and you
just like I'm a goddamn person yeah just
like you yeah you know that's true I
hope you guys let's stay alive for a
long time yeah I can't talk to younger
people when I'm 90 I need you guys here
oh just interview each other and give
each other shitty answers no remember we
read that grumpy podcasting that email
about that we read that thing about
people apparently that don't that are
separated at birth from either their
child or their parents can have this
thing happened where if they don't let's
say they don't see them for years and
years and years because that bond isn't
formed and then they see them 20 years
later they can actually be attracted to
them right this has the because the
bonding wasn't formed at the very
beginning right to beat your mom yeah no
I'm sorry good somebody emailed this
Torian hey Hitler's I was adopted at
bless you excuse me I was adopted at
birth but when I was 17 my brother found
me on MySpace he showed my sister my
myspace page and she said he's cute at
the time she didn't know what I looked
like only that she had a brother that
was adopted before she was born
he laughed and told her I was her
biological brother Wow a few months
later I meet my biological brother of
course he brings up what she said when
she first saw my pic he her and I
laughed awkwardly and carried on with
the conversation definitely weird though
I would not date my sister see you in
st. lous tits in October Ryan Wow
so that thing happened where she saw him
she was like that's he's cute yeah
and then he fucked her later but not
right interesting
yeah so that we're carrying this topic
on that's really nice
yeah about being attracted to your city
yeah we should do that I don't need to
know I think you should kind of talk
about it all the time this podcast is
called your mom's house should be about
family date your mom totally true and
how far you'll go with said family she's
right he's right what's wrong that was
the premise of the podcast if you look
in the description on iTunes the in says
nothing I'm just like you guys aren't
attracted to any of your cousins I mean
you could tell when they're you know you
can tell like goof I'm glad I didn't get
their genes like those ones but yeah
yeah that's basically it yeah oh yeah
let the dogs out
yeah but the dogs out there dinnertime
okay what are you gonna do who's out I'm
just gonna let them into the house
really aren't there a couple stories
where uh there was a story like last
year where you know where it's father
and daughter yeah and they don't know
each other and they get together or
there was also a story I think last year
was fraternal twins a man and a woman
yeah we're really attracted to each
other and they were gonna get married I
think they even might have got married I
wish I had more deal there was a there
was a mother and son that did yeah that
one we have we've had that one
extensively and that one is 100% super
disturbing it is cuz the damage is
already done
yeah marriage isn't afterthought oh my
god you've already blown your son oh
yeah I mean it you can't do that man
they they got arrested though yeah and
then the kid
stood for it yeah there's a lot of times
they don't want to break up right like
wait listen no we're in love they let me
this is a I can actually show you what
they look like if you're interested yeah
this is them oh my god hmm falling in
love with him he said are you really I
said yes I am he's saying you know what
I was scared let you know too I am too
both consenting adults if if it comes
down to it you know
it's just like the gays they're you know
as long as they're all retain everything
is fine but this cliff didn't make sense
to us for a long time until somebody
mentioned that thing about being like
now not that I encourage it right now I
feel like oh oh I think that's what
happened I think they didn't see each
other for 20 years and then this thing
morphed into something that it's not
supposed to be now did they go both go
to jail for murder no they both have the
teardrops or is that like a genetic
thing it looks like them inside it looks
like yeah incest is the new black sneeze
from last week you're the worst
oh my god that's gonna be a gif yeah man
you want to see some nasty shit yes oh
right here are we here for
[Music]
what is that that shit that is the
question dude why was she shitting on
the bed I don't know I think it's just a
way to say hey we don't like you like
you know more like she was ready to
explain it to anybody he didn't she
looked like you
thats why i don't airbnb anymore he says
she took a sham move shit did you hear
that at the end yeah yeah why couldn't
she make it to the toilet maybe she was
like that was there an anal sex thing
going on here discuss - dude I think she
was fucked up and I don't know have you
ever shut the bed cuz you're so messed
up no never
I've seen in Trainspotting yeah by the
way that's a lot it wasn't like a little
spot no and it was kind of hot dogs do
it like it trails yeah why did it drag
out she took an enormous you tried to
run away from the shit I think okay so
that's it there we go the digested
breadcrumbs here we go brown Locke Jana
yeah submit to the court my client had a
ferocious bout of diarrhea here's what
happened she was in the bed she felt it
she made me didn't feel it coming I'm
accident I acted in the bed and tried to
run to the toilet and then running to
the toilet left shit splash shit shit
marks that could be it
not very apologetic now I would be like
guys this isn't like me this is never
happening
I'm very sorry and didn't I say we were
gonna split this room anyways now just
let me dry my hair in peace please maybe
she was embarrassed
she's clearly embarrassed mortified to
eat she's mortified right now why don't
you at least clean the sheets I feel
like I would have ripped the sheets off
of course clean that it means your shit
you're in so you can throw the shit on
the hall it's like fair game
tough life is now like if you make a
mistake like you shit the bed someone
puts a camera on you examines you look
at this makes you look this bitch and
then immediately puts it on Instagram
right because it gets bigger if you'll
notice Jana yeah allow me to the it
looks as though this turd started there
because it was like smaller turds and
then the turds got bigger and bigger as
she approaches the toilet so it looks as
though she tried to make it to the top
[Laughter]
lack over what's the word I'm looking
for remorse the highest she didn't even
try to clean up that's the crazy part
especially from a woman so much saying
so crazy I mean I feel like as a dude I
would be running in there and being like
I know this is crazy
but even as you guys are yelling at me
I'll be like yeah yes I wouldn't want
somebody to see the shit there's my shit
yeah yes so embarrassed are we looking
at a group of people here who are into
drugs and just rented a hotel room even
though they don't really know each other
that well possibly could be it sounds
like you're high
fuck right you're on your I hope I mean
I've been I've been blackout drunk a
number of times I'm never here I've
puked yeah I puked like in my sleep when
I was that's how you die yeah but I was
faced in choked on it
oh yes I did one really bad sleepwalking
thing where I walked out I was 19 I
walked out of my dorm took over took a
right and just these girls dorms and
open up their laundry basket and piston
in a laundry basket
whoa I had no recollection of it
whatsoever did somebody see you doing it
yes really so I came back to my dorm the
next day and they're like there it is I
only have four beers that's exactly
where my bathroom would be at my parents
house but I mean that's grounds for
expulsion yeah one time in college I
went to sleep with my dorm room unlocked
because I think my roommate was gonna
come in later and she'd never care
whatever I woke up in the middle of the
night to a girl pissing on my carpet yep
she was fully squatting and piss a
stranger I'd never seen this girl on
campus before and I go I I think you
have the wrong room you need to leave I
turn the light on I thought it was my
roommate I would need to leave she goes
oh I just came in here I was gonna read
this book and she picked up a copy of my
book and then she laid on my roommates
bed and started to read the book and I
go you need to get out of here right now
I'm calling Public Safety you need to
get out of here and she's like oh okay I
think she was sleepwalking or she's
really high and she pissed on my floor
got into my roommates bed and read my
roommates book and I was like you need
to get out of here you need to get out
of here and then she finally was okay
and she was dazed and she left it was so
bizarre my soul of course and I called
Public Safety and I filed a report like
yeah it was crazy it was bananas wait
when you when you the next day when
people were like here he is yeah that's
nuts
no I know it's nuts because they weren't
really that mad at me that's what's
crazy or they must have really
understood what was going on
I suppose they they say I don't feel
like I would be that cool they said they
walked me back to my own
but it's like I still have no
recollection of it whatsoever not like
bits and pieces do nothing yeah and I
was drinking that night for beers though
that's not really a four beers kind of
move no for me it would be I mean I had
some Everclear blackout that's different
you know yeah what is that what's your
alcohol yeah it's like grain alcohol
we've missed it with Gatorade yeah and I
mean I mean crazy shit what is it with
boys and Everclear like freshman year in
college guys got a one-up each other and
they got to do more it's about how
fucked up can you get yeah cuz that's
the goal most interesting man in the Dos
Equis commercial it's the world's most
fucked up man that's for sure that's
what you want to do and I remember beer
boring and shit and I think the next day
after those we would never no one was
ever like that was fun right it was
always panic because because of the
blackout you had no recollection so I'd
be like what happened and then you have
the anxiety of somebody telling you
something terrible yeah so it's like it
would always be like you know your
friend would start with their head
shaking you're like what like that kill
somebody you know and then they're like
well no but I think I got like it's a
strange thing when you're robbed of your
memory yeah you feel terrifying it's
terrifying man it's not supposed to be
like this ya know it's a scary thing
you've never blacked out I've done acid
too much at one time and that's that
warps your sense of time but I told you
about that one where I went to a thing
with work people when I started
interning here in LA yeah and I went to
that sushi place uh-huh and we were just
I was just yeah it wasn't ever clear but
I was pounding yes sake and stuff yeah
and then I was talking to a group of
them and I was super fucked up and then
you know they told me I don't remember
he like was cute telling a circle of
people oh my god and then the guy told
he goes after you puked you know and you
can you puke yeah bit yeah yeah I was
like spitting like everybody's like yeah
and they used you turn back he went
right back into the stage and then I do
stole that from I have a vague
recollection of being you know escorted
out like security and be like get this
guy at it right well was the story why
was all important think I think I just
liked holding court just enjoy you know
what to think because it can't feel good
when you're that age just to get super
hammer like just vomit every time you
drank no no no no but I should have
nobody's always goes that hard yeah I
also you know I didn't know how to do
like have a drink and just hang in joint
if I mean if something wasn't exciting
going on I'd be like well just keep
drinking you know there's no action it's
like just keep drinking that's the
mistake I would make yeah I would just
hang out for too long everybody well
conversations are kind of over with
everybody I'm just gonna keep drinking
till something happens or before uber
was around I go out in LA I'm in my
twenties and just be stuck at places oh
my god and crowded you can't really talk
to anybody I just I guess I'm just gonna
drink
yeah disaster of course I had that the
worst part of that one of the puking one
was that I would that was like a
Saturday night mm-hmm
so you recover Sunday yeah Monday I went
to that job is that one you didn't go
into hard times in college I had some
blackout drink thing with where I was
interning and then I went back to school
and when I went I got hired by the place
to work there there was a lady who I
don't know she was she was 20-some years
older than me
who would kind of like say you know when
somebody says something with like a she
had she was delicate about she was
tactful about it but like almost
implying something is there and I was
like what is up with like not even like
that there's something whenever she was
like saying she would imply something
familiar you know like I didn't even
know her I'm like who is this ha ha ha
so I remember after a week of working at
this place I go have you seen I don't
remember her name like the way Shannon
looks at me or says uh like some things
and they're like yeah I mean don't you
think that's kind of weird like I've
never even met her and they go you made
out with oh my god that that before you
left
oh yeah yeah at the bar you made out
with her in public at the bar in front
of everybody here everybody knows that
you guys made out I was like what I had
zero told you must have loved that
moment oh the other no oh yes
what could feel better than to be like
you don't know this was not attractive
woman lady I think at the time I must
have been quite the I was her getting
her groove back her so I was 21 right
she was 44 45 yes and she what would she
look but she looked like the pizza dump
lady or and she wasn't that bad she was
just a big dick and balls
very nice dick nice cock she had a hairy
ass it was my style but she she was very
plain plain Jane like very very just act
like unassuming you would walk right
past her I didn't think anything of it
you know and and I I mean I can't
believe in which when I was finally so
great I remember being like and I just
what I decided to do was just act like
everything was completely you mean when
every 20 year-old boy does just act like
no yes yes that's what you do at the
office anyways though I'm so yeah yeah
yeah just pretends what Don Draper does
is what I do
yeah that's true because I also hooked
up with I hooked up with someone more
age-appropriate at that office
and then I acted the same way I was like
I don't know you and then oh my god but
actually that I not obviously working in
offices for the rest of my life but that
experience taught me how horrible an
idea it is to hook up with anybody that
you work with I mean like I know it's a
lesson you can't learn through somebody
else I can appreciate that but I've told
especially other young guys I've been
like don't do it it'll make work
terrible just does a big one for me it's
it's you've done and yeah and nothing
bad even ever happens yeah done it twice
I just hated how much people were my
business yeah it sucks man and it goes
from this is like an episode of Seinfeld
it goes from that being the person at
the office that's like really cool with
you did that being the person you're
like avoiding hi gives you trouble you
know what it taught me to respect I
respect more as I got older the person
who has zero social interaction with the
people they work with that's a smart
person
that is the smartest person in the
office the one who's just like I can't
make it anything on Friday or Saturday
yeah I'll see you man well and here's
the bummer of hanging out with coworkers
at least I in the past I would try yeah
is that you go out to drinks on the
Friday night or the Thursday night and
now you're in the bar but you're all
talking about work yeah oh it's and I
was like why I don't want to talk about
the TPS reports and the you know Z files
or whatever the fuck you're still at
work I don't want to talk about the boss
that's why we got you know drinkin in
hotels cuz we stay in hotels all the
time I will see you know go downstairs
yeah I have my my dinner and I see the
group yeah and they're all toasting and
then and there's ten yeah it's all work
stuff there like it he thinks he's a
manager watch he can't manage me exactly
you sit there I just like a different
background one of the most depressing
things to listen to yes is that office
Talk oh my god well you know Jeff is
though right you know where the copy
room was for like three weeks
Sanford do you know where we're at right
now
it's the worst now I mean the rare
occasion when you like I worked on shows
in production where the the staff was
cool you know when you go on like travel
trips or whatever to do things and there
be fun fun people but do you want to do
and far between see something by the way
this is a we had a talk about why
there's hot farts yeah yeah yeah and you
also know that hot is gonna be bad oh
you don't want you don't want hot I mean
once are hot enough right they're coming
out at 98.3 is it we put the call out
why is this why the rectal humidities
the end no adds bulk to stool cause it
to hold more water hot farts feel hot
because they are moist that's like an
East Coast fart yeah
confidence that this explanation is
correct 88% a bioengineer
Wow but that makes sense because what
happens when a farts super hot and it
stinks you go ooh something else is in
there there's usually a not nice shit
the check is in the mail
so you're we're back to farts pushing
the shit out or is it the shit that
pushes a fart chicken of the egg I know
that's exactly the question the debate
rages on a man who is here too most of
us here King a stripper has been he's
not farting again so don't worry because
I know sometimes people are like will
you cut out that farts already but he is
eating and I don't like it needs to get
bigger just to keep this motherfucker
buttoned up but it just keeps popping -
my god skin so big loves it look at that
BAM that's when I'm hard stomach but
he's having a hard time gaining weight I
feel yeah look at his face he's a skinny
guy can't
he's been doing this for years the last
time we had him in the grocery store I
feel like was more recent and he was
legit fat right fucking fat this might
be older this is older look at the video
quality walking chicken I bought the
motherfucker today at the store very
fucking chicken that I'm bout to state
here in devour because I'm a fucking
glutton I have a theory
my fucking Direction is fucking so Tom
and I were talking about this actually
is that I think that he's stolen not
solar just is inspired by Cookie Monster
oh alright if you listen to him oh boy
oh boy oh boy oh yeah there's a lot of
similar stuff himself yeah and he does
the same stuff that's true I think he's
a super fan of Cookie Monster early in
life this is a formative thing and then
he won't answer us we've offered money
so many times years he's gonna answer us
Joe for food ah good question
it's a good question you know something
he can't really even afford like maybe
like the biggest nacho plate of all time
maybe I can't even ninety ounce steaks
we gave him so many plugs he put out a
video that he dedicated to us but he
still wouldn't mention it right right
interesting talk time it seems like he
wants the publicity and the attention
yeah interesting to me it's like oil
it's like whipped oil there's eggs yeah
cuz a little bit and a lot is discussed
I don't mind chicken is lean protein
you're not going to get that fast with
that much man you're gonna gain some all
he has to do is go to Carl's jr. yeah he
wants to gain weight he's got stretch
marks or to see only a stomachs big yeah
yeah I'll do it stick with that
Budweiser Holmes I could tell him how to
gain weight just eat two or three
Western bacon cheeseburgers a week in
your car yeah
the beauty getting fat is you just wait
for inspiration you know you have
several epiphanies a day yeah go to fast
food that'll get you fat quick
calorically it's so it's too high
French we don't remember you get to soda
and we I wish I could pull it up I might
be able to let me see here let's see if
I can if I can yeah cheeseburger alone
is can be a thousand calories you're
making me hungry yeah I know what's your
favorite fast food in and out burger yep
yeah but I like it all what do you get
the double-double or get the
double-double do you go animal style or
I usually don't mess with animal style
get the raw onions Oh get pickles crazy
and what's a kiss nasty as hell that's
right are you looking for gee I was
looking for that for a king a stripper
he he we had him on the show semi
recently he was in a grocery store
yeah and man he was so what happened to
the fart a huge Oh
he kind of gave up on the floor now he's
just he's more into it to the gluttony
now you know so it's like when Jordan
started playing baseball he's got this
super talent yeah he's just like I want
to do something that's a great my dad
proud yes is exactly what we're for
you're overlooking the creative genius
that is King a stripper maybe he's
getting fatter so that the farts are
bigger
about that no no about that I have not
thought about that
he could be such an attractive person
he's got a good head of hair this guy
can face yeah he could he could go the
other way
he's now full fuckin fully committed to
being the grossest but like fattest
fartiest guy on the planet he just
doesn't give a fuck you know a forsaking
love I'm pretty sure he doesn't have a
girlfriend who could put up with that
that's too much it's I mean it's one
thing if you put on weight but it's
another thing if you're publicly right I
mean you're choosing that over human
love he's farting on it breakfast for
being in cheese burritos lathered with
two big-ass eggs slathered yeah a third
isn't the right and he would do that he
was doing he was doing those videos
[Laughter]
doughnuts on the food extra gross
there was nothing you just farting on a
plate of food it was just extra nasty he
wants me to nastiest but he is yeah
always here's the thing with King a
stripper is that he never stops
entertaining he business he's always the
question is he'd be doing stuff like
this
I just clapped back as the kids say yeah
what do you be doing this is there was
no internet if there was no one to show
that's I don't think so not provoking
though he would not there's no way you
need an audience it's the exactly and
you can't just do it at the bar on
Saturday night like you can't you can't
do the open mic this way yeah if a man
farts in the forest man and no one's
there smell it not millions I don't know
I can't prove he does what he does in
any public setting gets you removed from
your public like even if it was like a
patio you know I guess
open-air patio like at a mall yeah if he
was like farting and eating you gotta
fucking go it doesn't matter you gotta
leave you know it's interesting public
park yeah get out of here he couldn't
exist without the internet know what
internet created yeah
but I'm wondering if like you would even
have that idea like if you would even
have that idea all right no because I
would really want to do it if no one
there was no vibe here's my theory he
probably started doing it in school
grade school that's where you start a
talent like this and the other dudes
we're like that guy's awesome like you
can fart you can burp you've got there's
always that one gross guy in school they
can do all that cool shit and also the
burp burp contests are real exact thing
is drinking too much it's like bunch of
dudes just want to do it the best right
that's how skateboarding got in many
nasty bay right yes this is a grade
school talent that the internet kind of
nurtured tell me before we go too far
and forget where you're going to be in
September where you can see oh come see
me at the Tampa improv on September 13
okay you're gonna be happy you're gonna
be there September 13th yes that's Ybor
City oh yeah yeah with the Y and the B
tampon that's a part it's like a party
party place man I feel like wild
chickens out there just like wild
chickens in the park yes probably wild
chickens the full-charge calm the full
charge Power Hour on iTunes that's all
you need to know I didn't mean
interrupted it Bob no no no I mean okay
let me think about this for a second
you wanna you want to entertain the ho
debate this is met that way yes on on
the interwebs this dude makes a good
point about hos let's see if you agree
hey man I just got into a big debate
with this female
because she gets mad cuz I'm on
speakerphone with my nigga and he say
where the hoes at and I'm like listen
couple over here right now she get mad
tuck my no hos over here but I'm like
look I wasn't calling y'all hoes
individually I was just saying it the
hose is over here you know that where do
we start with this guy it's an
interesting linguistic debate it is I
think I should pay him the respect to at
least let him let him continue
explaining sure because you may or may
not agree with him but I think it's an
interesting point if you don't know the
hose is any group of females I don't
give a fuck of its Oprah and Gayle if
it's a group of hoes it could be CeCe
Winans and her sisters if they to gather
data oh you know women together is the
HOS like stop getting mad because we use
the right term like when it goes by
itself it's a goose but when it's a
bunch of gooses dimers geese so you
think it's a goose are you mad as hell
when a nigga say look at them geese and
she's like no no geese is over here
bitch agree upon that vernacular then I
guess he's right I mean my issues with
the speakerphone just beautiful
I hate conversations on speaker we're
big time anti speakerphone Congress it's
an epidemic
it is a horrible thing it's just the
lack of self-awareness the lack of
consideration for your fellow man yes
especially in in public and enclosed
smaller spaces waiting rooms you know
the the gate at the airport it's like
yeah yeah yeah your lack of
consideration just speaks speaks more
volumes than your cell phone does it is
fucking so indicative of how
self-absorbed you are to have that loud
ass speakerphone conversation you're a
dick that's everything I wanted to say
more on point
they have different definitions of hos
the kiss girlfriend in question she
thinks it means literally prostitutes or
the girls were going to be
looking tonight that's right and his
definition is just a gaggle of women a
group of one or more it's just a listing
then the conversation becomes or the
argument becomes is that acceptable is
it acceptable that's somebody's
definition does it could be different
than yours and and it could be a
definite word that you don't like but
maybe the definition suits that person's
own how about you though as a woman oh I
don't like to be called a hoe personally
but if if if somebody was like looked
around was like saw you I was like
houses over here I mean yeah I'm not
offended I know it takes a lot to offend
me but I would be like really dude you
know if I can call me a prostitute like
that's a little I think ultimately he
don't like this girl anyways though
there you go around it that's you know
truth of it the truth of is and he does
think she's a ho if he the truth is if
he ended up fucking that girl I probably
make this video and then he'd be happy
that the ho actually was shit on my
sheets
[Laughter]
my god so true though he does not
respect her no no you never call your
number one boo-boo no oh no matter no
matter what your definition if there was
some old-ass women right next to him he
wouldn't say if his mom was around yeah
what if it's his mom and her sister they
hos definition they are interesting he
would change that shit up right yeah you
would have a different definition Gail
it
he said Oprah get Oprah yeah anything
else you got gene would you rather 'z oh
fuck
I didn't realize we're doing this right
now we got a perfect perfect person here
to break down so would you rather yes
I'm just glad we got my dick out of the
way so many years ago should we remember
drink the top layer
[Music]
okay so we haven't we haven't talked
about this yet but Tom and I came home
last night from our vacation to discover
that we have a rat
nothing fuckin rat got in there's
droppings yeah I'm so upsetting and I
guess there are some workers here
painting and they left the doors open
and that's how I'm assuming because it
didn't exist we had somebody staying in
the house yeah pet sitter yeah but but
obviously the doors are probably open
for a long time yeah so in light of our
rat debacle we've called somebody today
and they're we're getting rid of it but
okay would you rather live with one rat
just one rat permanently in your house
forever and you're just always wondering
where it is if it's gonna crawl in your
face where it's pooping if it's crawling
on your snacks or I don't like it or you
live in the backyard what do you mean
you just live in the backyard outside
uh-huh with the pool though with the
pool do you have a tent yeah you give a
tent you shower with the hose it's like
camping all the hoes are there you've
got some lemon trees back there it's
real nice grass I think eventually you
would befriend your rat friend you know
you'd be like the rat here you'd be at
peace with all the rat shit eventually
you'd be at peace with the rat the rat
is terrifying in its newness as well you
know like you go what but imagine if
it's like a years gone by I think
started to learn your routine too I
think that likes you that much it comes
out at night he comes out in the morning
he starts to get your routine down I
would get a pair of boots and live with
the rat yeah he's like no he's dropped
food over here
you know I'm right over here yeah that's
another thing you do is start feeding
the rat so then you start controlling
right I haven't had experience with this
but then you start controlling like
their meals yes keep busy for you that's
what no no no you can't the idea is you
have to live with this thing permanently
in your home so if you're indoors you
have a rat buddy that lives with you or
you live outside where there are rats
aplenty I really really don't like
rodents I don't like them no and I still
think I would take the indoor living I
just don't want to live outdoors I don't
I'm not it's too hot here right now
it's terrible people don't know we're in
we're in California in Southern
California it's fucking I hate camping
too I just I'm not good at it I wouldn't
do it let's see what's the ground you
know a tent has a floor but it's really
just it's 102 here right now it's hot as
balls fuck that man so we your aunty are
gonna take the rat outside I'm gonna
take living in the backyard really yeah
I get used to it eventually
and I would like build like a Hut
situation or a yurt of some kind
104 tomorrow just so you know I'd find a
way to cool myself I like sleeping
outside in the summer I'm supposed to do
a phone call all right well I could see
that yeah especially I didn't know
you're allowed to build you can build
yeah you can build like a cabin or ya
know you just can't you can't take
indoor showers and stuff I get used to
it what do you got the pool that's true
you may be taking chlorine showers okay
here we go
would you rather is it so this is this
is the next one okay would you rather
every time you take a shit you're wiping
with your bare hand mm-hm
but as many times as you want I'm
listening or you can use toilet paper
but you can only wipe once yes this is
easy and then we all know this from mom
history yeah you wipe once and you take
a shower I mean this is so oh my god
interesting I mean just like you just
had this savant on right now now just so
you guys know I know I know now this was
Oh back to your quarters half of this
was addressed on the live show just you
know and it had a crazy response but I
thought I would put a little twist on
the game so yes you know this is kind of
a callback to the right right yeah it's
kind of a variant it is a variant I
really feel like I really feel like I
mean Matt kind of solved it no I know
but always being there that is a
horrible horrible life so I feel like we
get a one wipe life is terrible one like
a one way of life we know what we are
special one way play try it
I still by the way I got such I put a
call out to what should I name my new
special huh and so many people said you
better call it just glass and yeah just
it's a good time yeah but I feel like
it's too ridiculous I feel like as
disgusting as it is I wouldn't want to
be able to keep wiping oh my god
and then cleaning that that is so foul
but then your hands get covered in shit
all the time
you think about that song yeah like it's
better to have a shitty ass than a
shitty hands
yeah that's an ancient proverb I think I
would rather do one good because
sometimes I wipe there's nothing there
there's no good to go shoot and burn
what you're Ross smells like don't your
cock and balls smell like if you have
one good wipe you know you know what
you're doing we've all been there where
there's only like a couple sheets left
yep you can really be very efficient you
move slow apply pressure that goes with
like single sheets left sweat sweat
sweat in it but a man to have one wipe
all the time there's some shit where
you're like oh this is a half a roll
like easily yeah and then knowing that
you have one there yeah I've even
thought about using the cardboard
imagine this wait imagine this
listen to that you give you thought of
using the cardboard yeah to wipe but I'm
just saying imagine this imagine one of
your nastiest like like the shit where
you go like I'm gonna 15 minutes yeah
what would it be like to do one wipe and
stand up and pull your pants up what
would that do you like it would that be
good yeah it would ruin the rest of your
day you better hope you take that shit
at night yeah but but listen to what
full charges saying is that you would
get so strategic you would figure out a
way to fold that paper into like 16
pieces that you would fucking do it
I don't know it's tough it's a tough
choice one you're gonna have an itch yes
in this scenario you're a nasty guy yeah
or girl
ah yeah all right before we leave again
listen to the full charge Power Hour
check it out I got a couple episodes
with Tom and Christina on him you have
solutions all right and you're gonna be
one night only one night only
Tampa improv September 13th you
motherfuckers better be there check them
out do your house I'm gonna smack the
shit out of you there it is
Christian's uh you can check her out at
Christina P calm no Christina P
online.com sorry Christina Pete official
name change guys you can say thousand
right you do you can you can go see
Christina do it stand up now we're
talking there you go
Christina has always had the weirdest
emails to to go with the websites oh
yeah what was ill has she still has most
of them there was the one I remember
when I started dating you that was a
weird name some B's weird name yeah no
your email address at one point was like
God hates sorry no no no yeah never go
ahead oh my god like why it was like why
can the blacks vote dark oh my god Gina
catch me in Charlotte at gmail.com oh my
god
tiki torch tiki torch burning all right
we got a song Matt Mercer who's been
hitting home runs on the songs said I
haven't ever heard this this is in the
file it's called fuck me tonight cool
it's the outgoing song
Matthew foolish Ron the full charge
thank you for my pleasure always a
pleasure I mentioned before you got here
that Australia we're going to go in
April I'm down man is uh I'm just you
know September 13th that's the only damn
visit that's busy it's gonna be bananas
dude thank you guys for listening fart
bananas farts regular banana fart Nana's
hygiene hygiene
[Music]